I'm Lindback and I'm a math teacher have
been for years and years over 30 years I
wasn't aware of Khan Academy till my son
who was a freshman at Clemson University
in South Carolina came in one day and
said mom you really need to be using
Khan Academy and he said um here's the
TED talk on that he's believer in that
and I listened to it I said yeah you're
right I do so that was about two years
ago when you're relatively new and I
introduced it our community college and
we've been using it a lot we actually
have it on all our websites and we
really push it out as a way to help the
students in all the math classes didn't
say they really liked it they're using
it in calculus they're using it
especially in college I from college
trig where we have a high attrition rate
and we're really trying to get them to
use it more before they come to class
and and because we really don't we
haven't pretty there's no need for us to
go out there to produce what you already
have that's the point we're trying to
get across and now we're trying to use
problem-based learning but have them
view the video before they come to class
and help them more that way we're not
having to reteach for instance the
differential equations when you're doing
the limit the idea of a limit and the
slope I mean it's a wonderful topic but
kids really take a long time to catch
that so they really need to hear it over
and over again and at their own pace I
think that's the biggest thing is
customizing learning where they can
learn at their own pace some kids get it
right away and that intimidates other
kids when they don't and then they stop
this way they can privately increase
their ability in their conference level
with something before they come to class